let's go next to tina from asheville
north carolina tina how are you
oh my goodness all right now tina if
we're going to talk you've got to turn
off that notification noise because it
is just it's going to destroy any
ability you and i have to communicate so
you got to turn off notifications and
discord
tina
can you hear me now david i i can still
hear you but those are still continuing
to bling if you can turn off uh
notifications that would be great
oh gosh i don't know how to do that it's
my first time on discord oh dear
okay it's still blinking it hasn't for
now
okay okay i think it was me because i
didn't know if i was muting or unmuting
okay
okay um
uh long time subscriber first time
caller uh thank you for picking on me
and i just actually wanted to ask you
about um how like how to speak about
hispanic people
and i just wanted to know like what the
difference
is between like
latin like if you're talking about
hispanic people in this country do you
refer to them as a latino or is hispanic
okay i mean i know you're argentinian so
i'm just wondering like which one
is is more acceptable listen there are
people who feel very very strongly about
this and they say the right word is
hispanic but not latino the right word
is latino but not hispanic there are
people who say that these words have
different definitions like for example
hispanic would include
spain
but not brazil
whereas latino would include all of
latin america but not spain with brazil
maybe being part of it or maybe not and
there's a couple other countries in
south america that you could argue
culturally or not not a part of latin
america
i am not like a big i think both were i
don't find either word offensive
i understand that the words may have
slightly different meanings but if we're
all trying to communicate in good faith
i know what someone means when they
refer to latino folks and hispanic folks
and i use both terms sometimes so i'm
not like a big stickler but there's
different elements of academia that
would have particular points of view and
you know you ask someone else you'll get
a different answer tina that's the truth
oh okay all right thank you so much
david my pleasure there's tina from
asheville north carolina with a number
of different technical aspects of the
call that dramatically improved as we
went
let's go next to d
b
from virginia am i pronouncing that
right db
hello yeah can you hear him yes i can
can you hear me yes i can what's up man
how you doing good how are you
i'm good man so i'm watching the case it
looks like
okay you're you're cutting out db so you
said
you're watching the case and it looks
like and then you cut out right when you
were saying what it looks
like it's about 50 50.
to me
50 50 in terms of all the charges or on
the on the homicide
like yeah all the charges pretty much
yeah i'm just not sure uh i mean how
how is the prosecution going to
eliminate
from the jury's belief
that rittenhouse really feared for his
life how are they going to prove to the
jury yeah that's what i was thinking
yeah
yeah that's what i was thinking too but
then again it's like
he pointed the gut at him you know what
i'm saying so it's like this is the
united states
you know i'm saying so well but hold on
a second
wait wait wait whoa um
rosenbaum didn't have a gun right
rosenbaum didn't point a gun at a kyle
rittenhouse the argument that
rittenhouse makes is that after the
first shot rosenbaum attempted to grab
the gun
we're already kind of in the weeds but i
i still see it as a big hill to overcome
to say he didn't fear for his life
but yeah this judge is crazy man
the judge's uh judge is definitely crazy
the judge is out there yeah i mean
listen i know that early jimmy earlier
jimmy from philly said the judge is
actually trying to help the prosecution
i don't see that at all i see the the
judge
interrupting on the day of the written
house testimony five or six times at key
moments where written house was sort of
falling apart um
i see the decisions mostly favoring the
defense i i see the judge more of as an
as an asset to the defense
yeah so it's like and another thing a
small thing outside of this
joke joe biden man i feel sorry like
past this year
man i live in virginia yeah slaughtered
and slaughtered bloodbath oh yeah there
was no it was no signs bruh it was bad
wait but you're saying you're saying for
the yunkan mcauliffe race right
yes man i was like nobody voted that i
knew you know nobody voted low turnout
in this election
yeah
so well it's uh virginia's gonna be a
real question mark for democrats uh in
the next couple years i think that's
clear
yeah yeah well we'll see
all right
thank you for the call yeah no i think
about it i'm gonna let you go because i
have so many people holding great to
speak to you i i do really appreciate it
we're going to take a very quick break
and then we're going to be right back at
it and take some more phone calls in a
moment
one of our sponsors is all form hands
down the easiest way to custom build
your own sofa you choose the premium
fabric you want you choose the sofa size
shape color even the color of the legs
you can customize every aspect of your
new sofa to make sure it's the perfect
fit for your home i got my first
all-form sofa a year ago i just got a
second one which is really exciting
these really are the sofas i would have
bought for my home even if all form was
not a sponsor you really can't beat the
quality the modern minimal design the
sofas are spill stain and scratch proof
you can buy one piece and start with
that and then buy more seats and
accessories to add on later shipping is
fast and free you get a hundred days to
decide if you want to keep the sofa it
comes with a forever warranty and you'll
get 20 percent off when you go to
allform.com
pacman the link is right underneath this
video